Ciao mariners bentornati ecco a voi un nuovissimo video ho deciso di farlo perché mi avete scritto in
Tantissime su instagram soprattutto le ragazze ovviamente perché è un video un po più da ragazza
E perché siete in ansia, siete in ansia perché c'è una domanda che vi
Attanaglia che ha la stessa valenza di ansia della  domanda cosa fai a capodanno e questa domanda è
cosa ti metti il primo giorno di scuola?
allora siete tutte in ansia soprattutto chi magari deve andare o in prima liceo o in prima media
quindi in una scuola nuova dove non conosce nessuno sì è vero
poche cavolate
L' outfit del primo la scuola è importante bisogna pensarci ci sono alcuni di voi che ci pensano
Da giugno e forse è un tantino esagerato ma sono qui per voi per aiutarvi per starvi vicino per sostenervi in questa scelta
Dell'outfit, del primo giorno di scuola partiamo subito
Come primo outfit ho optato per un bel jeans con toppino
Semplice bianco abbinato io l'ho scelto bianco ma potete metterlo anche nero di qualsiasi altro colore pastello che sia comunque semplice
fresco e di chi ha un'aria pulita
E questo è uno degli outfit più basic che ho ed è anche uno di quelli che io vi
Consiglio di più soprattutto per le scarpe che sono belle comode e
vi fanno sentire a vostro agio potete anche correre potete ballare potete fare qualsiasi cosa
e, scusate sto degenerando
Scusate per lo zainetto che è un po'  piccolo ma purtroppo in casa non
Ne avevo altri con cui fingere di essere ancora uno studentessa quindi perdonatemi come sapete l'epoca dello studio e
marina studentessa sono ormai
momenti molto lontani
non ce la faccio
il secondo outfit che vi propogno l'ho intitolato alla marinara diciamo perché questa magliettina a righe bianche e blu è molto nel mood
marinaretta lo trovo molto
classico molto
Elegante ma comunque sempre casual c'è una via di mezzo e giusto quindi per il primo giorno di scuola che si vuole essere carine ma
non troppo tirate
un altro outfit che trovo molto carino è
L' outfit salopette e l'ho chiamato così perché appunto è una salopette perché ho scelto questa salopette?! ne  ho mille
Nell'armadio sono tutte con gli shorts quindi molto corte vanno
Bene per andare in spiaggia al mare ma comunque non per la scuola
scordatevele sono troppo esagerate e
gli shorts per andare a scuola, quindi ho scelto questa salopette che ho preso qualche tempo fa
non L'ho messa molto perche non ho trovato occasione perché comunque Se devo scegliere una salopette ovviamente l'estate preferisco quella con gli short questa qui però
è Perfetta secondo me per andare a scuola perché è comoda non è cortissima la minigonna
E proprio li al limite, la puoi abbinare con qualsiasi magliettina un crop top di fantasia in carica quella volete
E la trovo molto carina un po diversa dai soliti outfit
Ed ecco un outfit che ho dedicato agli amanti di total black io sono un' amante del total black
inverno sono praticamente sempre total black
per questo motivo magari a settembre comunque in questo periodo qui
Cercherei di evitarlo perché per mesi e mesi vestirò solo di nero quindi
Io sinceramente non opterei  per iI total black però tante di voi mi hanno scritto che hanno intenzione di
Vestirsi tutte di nero una buona opzione secondo me più del  jeans nero e maglietta nera è una gonna
longuette
Quindi che arrivi
più o meno sotto il ginocchio con una magliettina magari infilata dentro è né sarà forse così
che crea appunto questo questo giochino che questo effetto piquet che è molto carino
Scarpe io continuo a mettere questo ma potete anche abbinare  magari uno stivaletto un pochino più autunnale
Ed eccoci arrivati al outfit più tamarro
Allora, scherzi a parte e io trovo molto stiloso si è abbastanza sportivo
abbastanza
''hippopparo''se lo vogliamo definire così però mi piace molto il pantalone
L'ho rubato a salvo e sono, I suoi pantaloncini quando va a giocare a basket
E ma ci potete abbinare  qualsiasi tutona  larga eccetera eccetera vi. Mettete una bella magliettina
Le scarpe ovviamente io non riuscirei con le scarpe diverse ma era per farvi vedere due opzioniquindi magari, dalla scarpa alta bianca
lo stivaletto cosi' oppure una bella jordan
in onore di valentina vignali sicuramente lei il primo giorno di scuola si vestirebbe così
o si sarà vestita perché anche lei
Non penso che sia più in età scolastica e l'occhiale ovviamente
Dettaglio in più nel senso immagino per primo di scuola
Si possa anche evitare nel senso va. Benissimo, anche così però
Io se uscissi con questo outfit g al di là del primo giorno di scuola mi aggiungerei anche il mio occhiale che è uno dei miei preferiti
Un giorno vi racconterò la storia di quel'occhiale
Signori e signore vi annuncio l'entrata dell'ultimo outfit che vi propongo in questo video
IN PIGIAMAAAAAAAAAAA
Ovviamente è uno scherzo ragazzi tanti di voi alla mia domanda cosa mi mettete il primo giorno di scuola
Mi hanno risposto il pigiama ovviamente perchè non avete nessuna voglia di tornare a scuola
Perché sapete che dal primo giorno di scuola vi
Dovete mettere sotto a studiare subire lezioni quindi mi immagino che non abbiate tutta questa voglia però dai scherzi a parte
Mettetecela tutta e quest anno zero debiti e studiate di volta in volta anche io lo dicevo sempre non lo facevo mai ma almeno di
diitelo almeno provateci
E niente un pigiama lo lasciamo a casa quando torniamo a casa
Ed eccoci sfortunatamente giunti alla fine del video che spero vi sia piaciuto e vi
Sia soprattutto servito a trovare l' outfit per il vostro giorno di  scuola o magari a darvi qualche idea
State tranquille tranquilli andrà tutto bene
Sarà un primo giorno di scuola fantastico io ovviamente sono qui ad aspettare i vostri messaggi che
In cui mi racconterete com'è andato ecco ci tengo molto e da questo video deciso di salutare
3 di voi in ogni volta che caricherò un video su youtube tutto quello che dovete fare è semplicemente seguirmi
Su instagram e scrivermi un bel direct con il vostro nome e
salutami nel prossimo video mi chiamo
estrarrò tra virgolette
selezionerò 3 di voi e ad ogni video
vi saluterò
mi raccomando se vi è piaciuto il video se non avete ancora fatto iscrivetevi al canale mettete un bel mi piace e
lasciate un commento
e soprattutto seguitemi su tutti gli altri social instagram musicali e facebook
ADOROOO